Hi, I'm Nic Steenhout, and
this is the work between. In
case you didn't know, I provide
transcript reviewed for accuracy
by a human for every episode at
the time of publishing. There's
a text-only transcript that you
could read if audio isn't abyss
media for you. There's also a
time transcript you can follow
along while listening if that
works better for you. You can
access those directly on the
podcast's website if they aren't
displayed by your podcast
aggregator, that's the
workbetween dot show. Before I
get into what the show is, I
want to say whose land it's made
on. This podcast is recorded on
the traditional, ancestral, and
unceded territory of the Stolo
Coast Salish people, the people
of the river, whose presence in
the Fraser Valley stretches back
1000s of years. I name this
territory because it belongs
with what this show is about:
the ways we decide whose lives
are valued, whose work is taken
seriously, and whose experiences
are treated as problems to be
managed. Those decisions shape
everything. This show sits
inside that. This is, was, and
always will be First Nations
land. That's not a formality.
It's consistent with everything
I, and this show stand for. My
guest today is me. A couple
people told me they'd be
interested to learn more about
my creative processes. I thought
about it, and concluded it could
be fun to have me as a guest on
my own show. To make it more
interesting, I invited a friend
and colleague to be the
interviewer. Mark Miller is
someone who, like me, works in
digital accessibility and
inclusion. He is a photographer
and majored in art. He also is a
martial artist, and he co-hosts
the Inclusion Impact podcast. I
have tremendous respect for him,
and was chuffed when he accepted
to play this game. I gave Mark
carte blanche. I didn't know
what questions he was going to
ask or what direction he was
going to take. It was great fun,
and I hope you enjoy our
discussion as much as we did.
Mark, thank you so much for
being a good sport and agreeing
to play the role of the host for
this episode.
You are very welcome, and
I want to thank you for inviting
me to do that. It's it's
honestly an honor. I think you
and I have long been fans of
each other's content, so for you
to think enough of me to invite
me in is a huge honor, and I
really appreciate it. And I'm
very excited for this
opportunity to get into your
brain a little bit, and not not
just around this accessibility
subject that you and I tend to
talk a lot about, but to
understand you, your art, your
creative process, all these
really cool things that you and
I haven't had a chance to really
dig into quite as much yet. So
this is this is going to be
great. On that note, why don't
we get started right away and
just tell me a little bit about
the artwork that you do and what
you know your processes around
it?
I would say I'm a serial
hobbyist. Over the years, I've
tried so many things, from
leatherworking to bone carving
to wool felting, but I would say
the three main creative
endeavors that I'm doing
regularly and that are sustained
are around wildlife photography,
particularly birds, around
quilting and around watercolor
and sketching.
What would you say? Like,
you know, at heart you seem to
be a maker, right? And you're
getting your hands into anything
where you can express yourself
creatively. What through that
process? What caused you to land
on these three three things as
your primary outlets?
You know, I'm not too sure.
Maybe in parts is if you try
enough pair of shoes, you're
gonna find one that actually
feels comfortable, but also, if
I think around the sketching and
the watercolor, I know if I go
back as far back as being 7, 8,
9, I always wanted to do drawing
and painting. My parents even
gave me an oil painting kit. My
grandfather built an easel for
me, and I gave up at the time
because it was too hard. My
cousin, who was a couple years
older, did stuff that I thought,
"Oh, it's so wonderful! I'll
never be able to do as good,"
and I kind of gave up. So over
over the period of my long and
venerable life, I've come back
over and over and over again to
painting, and suddenly I
decided, well, okay, enough is
enough. I'm gonna actually do
the hard work. I'm gonna do the
practice. People say, "Oh, Nic,
you have talent." No, I don't. I
have zero talent. There's not a
talented bone in my body. It's
all about perseverance and skill
building. Around sewing and and
quilting is a little bit similar
that my mother taught me how to
do sewing when I was a kid using
her old Singer sewing machine.
It was really more about being
self-sufficient and being able
to mend my clothes more than
anything. But I had that
exposure back then, and then I
worked with leather, doing hand
sewing leather, and I don't
know. It kind of evolved in when
I started doing quilting with
fabric. It kind of like the
piece of puzzle came together.
And photography. Well, I've been
playing with photography on and
off since I was a teenager, and
always wanted to do wildlife,
but never really had the funds
to have the gear that would
allow me to do half decent
shots. And and as I get older,
that became a little bit easier.
But it's certainly not a cheap
hobby. So once you get your
gear, you you keep the gear and
and work it to death.
You know when I when I
first asked you this question,
you sort of gave I think the
most interesting answer, and
that was I don't know I don't
know why I landed these things,
and then and then of course you
went through to clarify, but the
reason why that's interesting to
me is because I think it's an
honest answer, right? Like if if
you had asked me that question,
I I don't know that I could have
articulated out of the gate why
I've chosen the things I've
chose, and it just goes to to
show that art is a lot about
self exploration. The reason why
you may not have an answer is
because in some undefinable way
that art is working inside of
you to do to do something. So,
what I'm curious about thinking
about that, Nic, and you know
the the subject that you and I
do cross a lot is accessibility
and and disabilities. And I have
to feel I feel like there has to
be some sort of a connection
between you know disability,
your work and accessibility, and
that internal fulfillment and
exploration and and discovery in
all those things that art gives
you. Do you find that it
connects those parts of your
life, or is connected to those
parts of your life, or are they
really independent things for
you?
Well, they're connected
because it's all about me. I
mean, I'm not saying that
because oh, look at me-it's all
about me. But it really is part
of who I am and what I do. So,
in that sense, they're
connected. But I think I'm
feeding very different aspects
of my self with the creative
processes I do for enjoyment and
the work I do in accessibility.
There's a certain level of
creativity, I think, around
accessibility where you have to
put your thinking cap on, and
no, you you have a problem, and
you try to solve it, and you
figure it out, you nut it out.
But for me, accessibility work
is a lot more about making the
outside world better for other
people, whereas my creative
processes is about making me
better.
It's a great way to frame
it.
So it's it's backward
looking and inward looking.
Well, and then it seems to
me that there's a bit of, and
this is just my observation of
you, Nic, but that there's a bit
of an event horizon between
those two. Things that comes in
the form of some of the content
that you create for the
accessibility industry, you
leverage that your deep ability
to create and to, you know, I
think when you create, you can
bring things together. You
particularly have a talent for
for explaining complex subjects
to people who may not be deep
into that subject, but I think
that when you create that
content, I can see that creative
nature in you as a component to
that. So to me, that would be
that that that event horizon.
But it sounds like when you view
it for yourself, you really look
at it as something that is maybe
a break from what you would
consider to be a professional.
Like that's another way to work
the brain. Is that a fair?
Yeah, absolutely. As
someone who is disabled, working
in the field of accessibility. I
used to joke that accessibility
work is not a job; it's a
lifestyle, and and in many ways,
I can't not need a ramp when I
go to the store when it's after
5p.m. and I've stopped working.
So, accessibility. I always need
to advocate for that. The
sketching, the photography, the
the quilting is for me a way to
do things away from that. It's a
way to relieve the the pressure
of constantly being an almost
fight or flight reaction. There
was a great post from Sheri
Byrne-Haber on LinkedIn recently,
where she was describing the
spike of hormones that you're
experiencing when you're always
having to advocate for
accessibility, and then she took
it one layer deeper and
explained how these spikes of
hormones and stress and
everything gets exacerbated when
you start talking to other
people with disabilities that
are experiencing their own their
own things, and then you're
working in a community, so you
get very little relief from that
constant constant stress
reaction around facing a non
accessible world. So because of
that, I, as I'm getting older,
I'm realizing I need to have a
break to not burn out.
That cortisol management,
yeah, we need to burn it
all
down at some point, yeah.
And because I work with
computers so much, I mean it's
it's 100% of what I do. Having
activities that take me away
from the screen is wonderful. A
sketch, I can do that. I you
know I have a pen of a pad of
paper, a pen, a few watercolors.
I can be outside in nature doing
that. I can do this anywhere.
Yeah,
quilting same thing.
Whether I do it with a machine
or I do hand sewing, I don't
need a computer or or anything
to do that. The the wildlife
photography is a little bit
different because, well,
actually, you know, I don't work
in film anymore, and I need to
process my photo, so it requires
a screen at some part of the
process. But the advantages of
this creative practice can only
happen when I'm out in nature
looking at birds, animals,
listening to birdsong, to the
sound of the breeze and the
trees and all that-that's all
part of the experience that has
nothing to do with my work.
Yeah, or or your
disability. It's all stuff that
you're doing. It's just yeah,
and I think you know it strikes
me. There's a lot of there's a
lot of research, a lot of talk,
a lot of ancient sort of wisdom
out there around the mental
health benefits of being in
nature.
Yep,
and I think if you're
anything like me, Nic, what
you're describing is taking that
a step further, and with
something that's more tactile.
It's not your not digital. It's
not your computer. It's your
paintbrush, your your your
pencil, your sewing machine. In
the case of photography, it's a
little bit of in between, but
and actually participating in
nature, right? In in in drawing
back and forth, like like
engaging with it, engaging with
it. Do you so? In full
disclosure for your listeners,
I'm a I'm a studio arts major.
My background is in photography
as well, but I've dabbled just
like you in all of those things.
Being a studio arts major, and
so one of the questions or one
of the things I always get
curious about when I talk to
other artists like yourself is
the influences that they've had.
Is there anybody that you would
point to, either famous or
within your own life, that's
influenced the work that you do
artistically?
I have so many different
influences, and some I can tie
directly, and some are a lot
more vague. I think, in in large
part, my my interest in art has
come from the fact my dad is an
arts collector, and had several
friends who were artists. One.
One of my dad's friends' name is
Milienko Horvat. He's a he lived
in Quebec, but he's a Hungarian
modern artist. Was. He passed
away. So I've been surrounded
with pieces of art, mostly
modern art, but also pieces or
more classical paintings. So I I
think that shaped an
understanding of art is
important. I recently had my a
conversation with my dad, who is
telling me, you know, Nic,
you're doing these sketches, and
and that's great. But really,
you don't understand art. And
yeah, okay, thank you, I, you're
right. I do not understand art
because I don't spend time
trying to analyze it. I just
want to make it happen. Yeah. So
that, in part, is is why.
drawing and sketching and
painting is important in terms
of more direct influences with
what I like to do is is all the
urban sketching movement the
this idea of painting on
location from life capturing a
moment in time, and there's
there's a certain style that
comes out. I mean, everybody
does it differently, but but
there's a lot of line and wash
that comes out of that. I I like
to capture those those ideas. In
terms of quilting, I don't know
that I have any particular
influences. I've just always
liked quilt. I was lucky enough
to to travel through the U.S. We
were full time traveling in an
RV, and we stopped in Kentucky,
in Paducah, and there's a
national quilt museum there.
This was just before I started
doing quilting, and we spent
several wonderful hours
exploring that, which is all
around modern quilts. And then
my wife surprised me with a book
of how to make your own sampler
quilt entirely from scratch, and
I think I put in 12,000 stitches
in that product, and I'm really
happy with it. But that's that.
You know, my wife jokes that she
created a monster because after
doing that one, then I had to do
another one, and another one,
and another one, and and I
haven't had a chance to quilt in
last 18 months because we were
moving and work and all that,
but we finally have a room that
is a dedicated craft and gaming
room. So I'll be able to go back
and finish the projects I
started a year and a half ago.
Photography, I don't know.
Photography, I, you know,
there's all the masters of of
street photography. Bresson, in
particular, I like his style.
Adams, I like his style, but I
don't think I'm trying to
replicate what they're doing.
But it's more in terms of
Bresson, Paris, black and
white.
Yeah, yeah,
yep. Okay, now you're
talking about. I would not have
pronounced it that way, but I
think you're probably
pronouncing it correct since you
are speaking his native tongue.
Yeah, what I like about him
is this this approach of,
funnily enough, capturing real
life moment snapshot of time,
which in a way ties into urban
sketching, but it's it's this
decisive moment,
decisive moment. Now, what
we know of his photos, they're
wonderful, but we also, if you
dig into it a little bit, you
realize that there's a lot of
negatives that  never made it to
print, right? But to have that,
what's the word I'm looking for?
That it's that instant
spontaneity. To have that
spontaneity, whether you're
sketching or taking photos, you
you have to have taken 10,000
bad photos. You have to have
done 10,000 bad sketches. You
have to have put in 10,000 hours
in in quilting before things
start flowing. So to have that
spontaneity, I think is is is
what I'm hoping for at some
point. To to have enough
practice and skills and and
muscle memory to not have to
think about it and be
spontaneous that way.
Yeah. The... I want to dig
into a couple things here, and
in doing this, I'm going to
challenge your father's
statement that you don't
understand because you you
mentioned a couple of times you
talked about the street, whether
it's in reference to painting,
whether it's in reference to
photography and this sort of
urban landscape, which is very
interesting to me, Nic, because
what I know of your photography,
you've shared back and forth
with me, or nature photos, which
is very specifically the
opposite of that urban. But one
of the things that you said that
was really interesting is that
you liked that sort of street
art in in the on location art,
and I don't know if you've been
to the last time I was in
London. I was at the Leek Street
Tunnel, and the Leek Street
Tunnel is a place in London
where it's okay to do graffiti.
It's encouraged, and this idea
of creating art on location and
art that, in part and whole, is
probably temporary because
there's no rules, right? Or or
or the rule is is that if
somebody paints a picture, you
can come right behind them and
paint over it, or or somebody
may never paint over your
picture, like you don't know.
But to me, that urban art, that
temporary nature of it, that on
location, all those things, all
the things that you describe to
me-that's the true nature of
art, right? Because it's because
it's evolving. It is temporary.
It is when somebody paints over
a part of your picture, they
don't wipe out your picture, but
they add the overall gallery,
right? The overall impression.
So now, what they did becomes a
part of what you did, and then
there's this like bracket of
time. This bracket of time that
moves through time, and then you
know, in photography, there's
the decisive moment. There's the
it's sort of humans in nature.
Do you why do you why do you
think that you're drawn towards
those urban landscapes that are
moving and changing and
temporary and and raw? You know,
in in some ways. I mean, you're
talking about quilting and
nature photography in the same
breath, Nic.
Yeah, yeah.
What's the what's the
attraction there? Like, why that
dichotomy in your in your in
your esthetic? I'm asking hard
questions, aren't I?
Yes you are, and that's
wonderful. I think it feeds
different parts of my needs, but
ultimately, it's it's all about
quieting my brain. My brain
never stops. I have, I don't
have a diagnosis, but I'm 99.9%
certain I have ADHD, and part of
that is my brain never stops. I
go to bed, my brain doesn't
stop. I go to sleep, my brain
doesn't stop. It's always going,
except when I sketch, when I
quilt, when I take photos, so
these are different expressions
of how do I self-medicate
without medication, if you want.
Why urban sketching? Well, I've
always liked architecture. I've
always been interested in
architecture. I've traveled a
lot as a kid, and then been
exposed to to architecture in in
Canada, in Montreal, in the U.S.
in in Africa, in Europe. So. I
think there's beauty in
buildings, whether they're
300-year-old buildings or newer
ones. But also, more and more, I
want to include people in my
urban sketches because
ultimately, like accessibility,
it's about people. So it's tying
the human experience to the
environment. Quilting is a
different beast altogether. I
think it's especially the
patchwork part is is making art
that isn't related to the human
experience, but in the end, the
quilt is to be used. For me, a
quilt is not something you put
on a wall or put in a box and
forget about. A quilt you you
use it when it wears out. Well,
you make another one. So yeah.
So you said something
really interesting in there, and
you know we've got a lot in
common, Nic. And one of the
things I think we have in common
is sort of this diagnosed,
undiagnosed ADD. I grew up in
the '80s, and I'm
self-diagnosed. Well, I'm
diagnosed now with ADD, but
ultimately I didn't have that
diagnosis, and then also
dyslexia, and so it really
resonates with me when you talk
about these different artistic
endeavors quieting the brain, or
almost to me, it's almost like
just aligning thoughts that tend
to be sort of all over the
place, right? You know, do you
find that, like, think about
something like sketching? Is it
hard in and hard out for you?
And what I mean by that is
sometimes I have a hard time
through all that deciding I'm
going to sit down and draw
something, or that I'm going to
go out and take pictures. But
once I'm in that, I now have a
hard time stopping, and I have a
hard time not thinking. Like if
I leave a work unfinished, it's
on my mind until I feel like
I've finished it. Is that your
experience? Is that is that are
you are you narrowing your focus
once you get into it, on that
piece of artwork, or is it
something different for you? I'm
curious if do we have a similar
experience or if it's different.
Yeah, it varies for me.
Sometimes I say, okay, I'm going
to take half hour and do a
sketch, And I just fiddle. I
have my notes, my sketchbook,
and my pen, and I'm not getting
anywhere. And sometimes I kind
of thought, "Oh, well, I'm just
gonna doodle, and I end up
sucked in immediately. And I
lift my head, and oh, what do
you mean? Two hours have gone
by, right? And some days I I
want to do these things. Some
days I want to do sketching, or
I want to grab my camera and go
out. It's a beautiful day. the
The light is nice. It's not too
hot and not good cold, and I
just can't. I don't have the
spoons. I don't have the energy
to to get going. So it's. I
don't think there's a specific
pattern about that. But most of
the time, once once I start it,
once I actually do it, then I'm
so full in that you know the
world could drop around me and I
wouldn't know.
That's interesting. Yeah,
I would love to have that
experience where the world, but
I never have that. My ADD keeps
me on the surface all all the
time. This is really where I
wanted to end up here today
because this is interesting to
me. I was listening to your
first podcast with Mia.
Yep,
and I was learning all
sorts of things about you that I
didn't know, and of course,
there are things that we have in
common, Nic. Right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Believe it, believe it or
not, and one of them is that you
mentioned a martial arts
experience in your past, and I'm
I'm wondering, you know, within
the context of this discussion
of art. So I've got a I've got a
strong martial arts past too.
Does that does that is that a
part of this whole artistic
experience for you? Does it
influence it? Do the things that
you learned mentally and
physically do they do they play
a part in your artwork at all,
or is that yet another separate
outlet that you had in your life
or still do? I don't know if
you.
Very different. I started
judo when I was six years old
because I was being bullied, and
it was recommended that I do
something that would give me the
confidence to to stand up in a
way, and I did judo for 18
years. I didn't like
competition, and to reach black
belt, you either had to do a
technical approach, which was
longer and harder, or go through
competition, and people are
brutal in competition, and that
did not appeal to me at all. So
I didn't quite reach my black
belt in judo, but I did it for
18 years.
18 years is a lot of time
on the mat for
yeah
anybody yeah, and I'm
assuming. So I don't know a
whole lot about your history of
disability either, but I do
know, or I think I know, that
you're a wheelchair user. That
that's correct, right? Was this
prior to being a wheelchair
user? Is this something that you
did as a wage?
It kind of started fading
out. The judo faded out when I,
within about the same time range
that I started having to use a
wheelchair.
Okay.
But also towards the end of
doing judo, I I was traveling a
lot. I was a chef at the time.
Oh wow!
Which hey, guess what?
Another video there.
Yeah, and and I was slowing
down the judo, but I started
doing tai chi. I learned tai
chi, which is a lot easier to
practice on your own than judo
is, because there's only so many
katas you can practice. Although
in in a way, Tai Chi is katas.
But I started doing judo
judo is specifically
designed to be to have an
opponent in the
yes
practice.
There there are some katas
you can do, but it's yeah
yeah. Tai Chi is is more
of a inner
Tai Chi is is a more
internal practice. I mean,
outwardly it looks like you're
doing movements, but it's all
about the how the internal goes.
And from that perspective, Tai
Chi is is good for my brains as
well because it's a form of
moving meditation. I
occasionally try to start tai
chi again, but it's it becomes a
question of juggling how much
spare time do I have in my day
and where do I want to focus my
energies?
Yeah.
So at the moment, I choose
to focus my energy in in
sketching. And
I think the wonderful
thing about any artistic
endeavor, and and and including
ones that where you move your
body, like like the martial
arts, is that you can bring it
back in times in your life. So
drawing's been that way for me,
where I go through long periods
of time without drawing, and
then I, for some reason, I have
a need and I come back to it. So
I think that's a brilliant
thing, particularly with
something like Tai Chi, is that
if it doesn't provide value for
you at this time in your life,
then it doesn't make sense to do
it,
yeah,
but if but it may provide
value in a in the future, and
you there's nothing that says
you can't circle back to it, you
know. And then so and I don't
want to stay on this martial
arts thing too long because
really we're here to understand
you as an artist, but I've got
one one final question because I
can't1.
more thing. There was
one more thing because I
can't help myself. But have you
ever thought about retooling
your 18 years of judo to be into
a a wheelchair practice where
you could use the same
Principles adopted for adopted
for wheelchair.
I do
or did I just come up with
an idea for you?
No, I I I'm I think I'm
actually doing that, but not in
a martial art kind of way,
because 18 years of judo and six
years, solid six years of tai
chi, forms how your body moves.
Yeah,
forms how you open doors.
Even I mean, the way you open a
door, you know. In a wheelchair,
you can't just pull on the door
because if you pull on the door,
it's not the door that's going
to open; it's your wheelchair
that's going to move, right? So
the way you you use that push
pull that that equal and
opposite forces, the way you're
you're moving, all that is in a
way integrated into my
subconscious, and
makes sense.
It's funny because years
after stopping judo, 20 years
after stopping judo, I actually
took a pretty nasty tumble out
of my wheelchair. I was going
down a hill, and my wheels
locked on a rock, my chair
stopped. I was going down, and I
flew out of my chair, and I
ended up doing a just a roll,
judo roll.
Yeah, you came just,
and that was it. Didn't get
hurt. Some people that saw me
tumble said, "Oh my God, Nic,
what the hell was that?" Looked
very spectacular to people
outside. But for me, it just
came naturally.
Yeah, it was just another.
How many times in your life had
you done that? And this was just
one. Yeah, that's. I mean, I
think everybody should study at
least the ukimi, which is the
falling part of judo in their
life, because I can't tell you
how many times it's come into
play for me, and if hopefully,
if you're a martial artist,
you'll never have to use the
martial arts in your life,
except for there's no way to to
avoid falling at some point in
your life. So you will. I always
tell people, like tell my
students, this is one of the
most important things.
Yeah, I'll teach
you, and I can remember
once running with my wife, and I
tripped over a root, and it was
just the same story. You know, I
went headfirst to the ground,
but I rolled up out of it, stood
up, and she, "Oh my god, are you
right? "I said. I looked at her,
just smiled, and she goes, "Oh
yeah, I forgot. Let's keep
going,"
you know.
But but I probably fell
four more times that day on the
mat, you know, in practice or
whatever. So it was just another
moment of falling. So, swinging
back into your your art a little
bit, right? We've talked about
you know you sort of have
settled on these different
things that that that resonate
with you, and they're all very
different. This is what's
impressive, right? Is that
photography and quilting could
we get much more opposite than
that, right? And then, and then
these things like drawing and
and watercolors kind of are
somewhere in the middle of that
spectrum. So I think it's
wonderful that you figured out a
way to kind of exercise this
full full spectrum of of
expression within within art. Is
there anything that you is there
anything that you you don't like
about your art, or anything that
you wished you had leaned into
more in the as you were sort of
coming up as an artist?
Several things. First, I
wish I had persevered earlier. I
really picked up watercolors for
the first time, and when was in
the late 90s? I wish I had kept
at it back then. Yeah, because
by now I would be. I assume I
would be happier with what I
produce. I am my own worst
critic. I'm getting a lot of
great feedback. People love what
I'm doing, and and it's good for
the ego. But when I look at what
I do, I'm rarely satisfied with
what I've done. I see all the
faults. People told me, "Hey,
your bird photography is great.
Maybe you should sell calendars
or or sell your art." And I'm
looking at everybody else that I
interact with that does bird
photography, and I'm thinking,
"Well, a the market is flooded,
and b I'm okay, and maybe I'm
better than people around me.
But the reality is, I'm just a
very, very basic bird
photographer compared to other
people. " So, from that
perspective, I, you know, I like
to share the work I do, but I'm
not often happy with the work I
do.
I'm I'm agreeing with you,
Nic, because you're descri
you're describing what I feel
just about every time I produce
something, and it makes me
wonder if if we're wrong or if
we're right about that feeling.
You know what I mean. If if if
everybody who's who's
photographing birds or or or
sketching looks at their work
and feels the same way, and
where I feel this the most in in
that same sentiment of like I
wished I dug deeper when I was
younger is with like figure
drawing. I learned to figure
draw in school, but I kind of.
Left it in class, and I've come
back to it at certain times, and
I'll do a drawing, and I'll be
very happy with it, and then
I'll look at it the next day and
be like, "What? Yeah, what did I
do? This is not good.
This is where, for me, art
is about the process, not about
the outcome. I am much more
satisfied with spending an hour
sketching a bridge than I am
with the finished bridge sketch.
Yeah, that's a really
great way to to think about it
and to to put it. What are you
most happy with when you look at
it and you go, "This is in my
art. I've accomplished. I'm so
glad I've accomplished fill in
the blank.
With sketching, what I'm
working on most right now is
perspective and values. So if I
nail perspective and values on a
sketch, it makes me happy. With
quilting, it's sharp seams,
points that are on points, and
and when I say points that are
on points, is is the corners
where two different or three or
four or five or six parts of
fabrics are meeting that they're
meeting spot on. For bird
photography, it's it's it's
getting close enough to the bird
to be able to have the eye sharp
at about level. I don't want the
birds to be all the way up or
all the way down, and I, I like
to capture motion. A bald eagle
sitting on a branch doing
nothing is impressive. They are
really big birds, but I've got
hundreds of bald eagles sitting
on a branch doing nothing,
right?
And and I said last year
when when I was out looking at
bald eagle migration, I said to
somebody else, like oh yeah,
they're just sitting there,
they're boring. And the person
says, what do you mean they're
boring? Well, they are. What
we're waiting for is the action
they're taking off. They're
splashing into water, grabbing a
salmon. They're grabbing each
other and swirling. That's what
you're looking for. It's for the
action, and what satisfies me
most is when I have that action.
I think that yeah, what
you described is is that
evolution, right? And it's the
decisive moment. So when you
were first describing that, it
was like, well, yeah, you know,
I don't know how jazzed I would
be about capturing a bald eagle.
Probably pretty jazzed, you
know, but just sitting there on
a branch. But then I also don't
know how big of a deal it would
be to catch a bald eagle eagle
soaring overhead, but to capture
a bald eagle in that moment when
it's just about to take off and
it goes through that expression
or whatever it is where it's not
sitting on the branch and it's
not in flight, but it's
somewhere in that moment in
between. I think that when the
term decisive moment was coined.
It was moments like that that
that they were thinking about.
That there's a particular thing
about only at that moment could
you click the shutter and
capture that. If they're in
flight, you could click the
shutter 1000 times. It's going
to look very similar. Or if
they're sitting there, you know.
That's right.
So I I completely I
completely understand, you know,
and I think there's something
when you hit that, like you feel
it, you know it, and it's it's
it's very very satisfying.
It it it's it's learning
the behavior of the bird too,
because you can capture that
great photo by sheer luck, or
you can know. Oh well, this bird
has been sitting there for this
long. It's starting to shuffle a
little bit on the branch this
way, and oh yeah, I know this is
coming. I need to be ready to
take that photo.
Yeah,
and it's
almost almost athletic in
that sense of of you know if
you're hitting a shot when
people are trying to defend you
in basketball-it's recognizing
the movements in the moment to
take the shot. It's a very
similar thing, and to your
point, it's the process. It's
all the work that goes before it
to allow you to do that. That
that you do it for. If you had
to, if you and I were going to
meet on a deserted island and
you were only able to bring one
piece of artwork with you to
show me, what would that be?
I've never seen any of your
artwork, but you have to bring
one one thing to show me. What
would it be?
One of my quilts.
Oh, that's very
interesting.
Because I can't help being
pragmatic and practical about
life, so I'm going to show you
this quilt, and we're on a
deserted island, and we need to
stay warm. So we're going to
wrap up in my art and stay warm.
That is a fantastic
answer. I absolutely love that.
I'm thinking it's going to be
like a picture or something, and
you're like, "No, we got to stay
warm. The so let's let's reverse
that. I'm coming over to your
house, and every piece of
artwork you've ever done is
laying out on the floor. What do
you what do you before I get
there? What do you hide so that
there is no way I will ever see
it.
My secret sketchbook.
Enough said.
I I have a sketchbook where
I experiment, ink, colored
pencil, gouache, watercolor,
brush pens, whatever. I just do
stuff in there, and it's for me
only. I will never show that to
anyone, and that relieves a lot
of the anxiety about
performance. So...
Are you hiding the
imperfection in your art in that
case, or are you hiding the
parts of your brain that are
coming out in that art, or both.
A bit of both, but a lot of
hiding my brain. You wanted to
explore my brain earlier, and I
nearly said, "Oh well, it's not
a very pretty place, and that
secret sketchbook allows me to
to express the often dark
thoughts that I have that I
don't want to a burden people
with or b make myself too
vulnerable about.
And that brings me back to
your attraction towards that
urban esthetic, which you you
called human, right? Because you
you said you know you don't want
to take a picture of a a rusty
fence in a brick wall. You want
to take a picture of a rusty
fence in a brick wall with a
person leaning into it that's
pensive, or with a person
hitting it with a hammer, or you
want that human human element in
there, and I think sometimes
those it it makes sense to me.
Your answer makes sense to me
because I think sometimes those
urban landscapes and that
locational art and that freedom
is this the surfacing of some of
that darkness, you know, like if
you're painting a still life or
nature or you're photographing a
bird, it's not doing that. But
when you're so deeply into the
human condition that you're in a
place that is 100% of a human
environment, with 100% of a
human reacting to that
environment, you're starting to
surface the that that that
depth. So I think that there's a
relationship between those
things. Well, I hope that if we
end up on a deserted island,
that you bring that quilt
because that sounds wonderful.
And I hope not to ever stumble
upon your secret sketchbook
because that doesn't something I
want to even get into, Nic. But
I hope that the things that you
need to surface out of that
sketchbook and into your regular
art, I I think that part of the
process is finding out how to do
that too. Yeah, you know,
yeah. There's there's
certainly things that I'm
figuring out as I'm doing
doodles in my secret sketchbook
that actually come out of there
and that I'm using in in
everyday things that I'm happy
to share with with other people.
Well, I'm gonna also say
secret sketchbook. Great great
title for a novel, not a bad
band name either.
I have so much musical
talent in me that if I played
musical instrument, I would kill
all the vegetation around me.
You know, they they say music
like plants like music. Well, my
music, they wouldn't.
I'm I'm right with you. I
yeah. Don't ask me to sing.
Don't ask me to keep rhythm. I'm
not going to do it. I think
we're we're we're getting close
to the end of our time. Nic, is
there anything that we didn't
cover, or anything that you kind
of want to bring up about you,
your artwork? any of it that
that that you think is important
that we didn't cross over.
Yeah, I would like for
people to think about me as a
multifaceted kind of person. I'm
not just that disabled guy. I'm
not just that angry crip. I'm
not just this digital
accessibility expert. I'm I'm a
husband. I'm a son. I'm I'm I'm
human, and part of that humanity
means that I'm going to be doing
sketching, I'm doing to be
quilting, and I'm doing
photography. And who knows?
Maybe, maybe a year down the
road, I'm gonna say, "Hey,
there's a new creative thing
I've just heard about, and I
want to try that. And I'm hoping
that people that see me bouncing
about from one to another to
another to another type of
creative practice. See it as
exploring creativity rather than
being aimless and not sticking
to something, because maybe the
practice I'm using right now is
different than the one I'm using
six months down the road, but
I'm still practicing creativity
rather than not sticking to one
thing.
One of the sayings that we
have in the martial arts that my
group of people have in the
martial arts is: we say,
"There's nothing better than
being a white belt. Everybody
wants to get to that black belt,
and we say the most fun that we
have is being a white belt, and
this oftentimes brings us to
study other disciplines. Right?
You said you did judo, you said
you did tai chi, and I've got a
bullet list, and I stick with
ones, but I also try other ones,
and I think it's that same
thing, Nic. Like you, art is a
process before it's a final
product, it's about the journey.
It's about the creation, and
sometimes the most satisfying
form of that is when you've got
something brand new, a brand new
skill you're trying to acquire,
a brand new medium you're trying
to figure out how to work with,
but something that is returns
you to the beginning and causes
you to rediscover from that
perspective.
Yeah.
So I don't think I don't
know if I'm sure you're talking
from a place of experience when
you say you hope people think of
you that way, but I, to me, it
just makes sense. It makes a lot
of sense, and I think that it's
really one of the ways that we
discover-we don't discover who
we are and the things that we're
good at. We discover who we are
and how we interact and react to
the things we're not good at, or
to adversity, or or novelty, or
whatever. So,
and I appreciate
you do that.
There's growth in
discomfort.
Yeah. Yep, 100% Then
that's where again, maybe we're
a lot of like, like people say,
"You want to go on vacation?
Let's go to you know the all
inclusive. I'm like, "Can we go
right in the middle of town? Can
we go find those people that
don't want us to be there? I
want to hang out with them,
right? It's there is there is
comfort for me in discomfort
sometimes.
Yeah,
you know, into having your
having the edge of your blade
ground against a little bit,
that that's what makes it
sharper. Well, Nic, I feel like
we could do 10 more of these,
and I still wouldn't get to the
center of who you are entirely.
Nor do I think I ever want to be
there because of the discovery
is the point.
Yeah,
this was amazing, and I'd
love to keep going. But I know
we've got to. We've got to.
I had a wonderful time, and
I'm so glad I picked you to
interview me. This was so much
fun.
I'm so glad that you
picked me too, and it was an
absolute honor. And if you if
you feel like you've got more of
a story, I'd be honored to step
back into this role anytime.
Mark, thanks a lot.
Thank you.
If you enjoyed this
episode, if you were inspired in
any way, or if you learned
something, please leave a rating
or review on Apple Podcasts, on
Spotify, or whatever podcast
aggregator you use. Ratings and
reviews really do help. Thank
you. And that's it. I'm Nic
Steenhout. This is the work
between. If this sounds like the
kind of conversation you like,
subscribe, and I'll see you in
the next episode.